hi friends welcome back to the
electronic triple 2016 it's good to have
you here we're almost done about 15
minutes left to talk about video games
so we're not got to talk about all those
shitty video games I'll talk about the
best video games that we saw here at e3
2016 Peter Brian hi hey Dan oh I'm so
good
good to have you here thank you happy to
be here Rob handler hey this is my first
time on hey first time on you've been
editing basically all of these videos
yeah little brain dad so yeah dumb you
let me know
dori yeah just had already their warning
yeah Michael Mike McCarty hey middle
name Mike mm-hmm you're on Browns with
the shirt good job
yeah great to have you here all of you
it's good to be here yeah wonderful I
want to talk to you about the best game
yeah give me something I'm gonna talk to
you guys about the best game that seemed
more favorite the favorite game that
seems to be just from listening to
conversations in around this war room in
just a couple of minutes but before we
get to that one let's talk about some of
our other ones we liked I played hard
any game so I'm really just gonna throw
this over at see you guys Peter some of
the games you've enjoyed playing your
your time here in the LA CC just like
you actually haven't had a whole lot of
time to play as many games as I have in
the years past a lot of interviews you
know a lot of like stage stuff Sonia I
thought really knocked it out of the
park seeing God of War kind of transform
from this brutal game into something
that's got maybe a touch of sensitivity
and emotion to it it's kind of
interesting mmm that totally caught my
eye you know there's just a lot of
different stuff even the Xbox one happy
to see that you know with the s yeah
that's it but I want to talk to you
about the Scorpio very briefly actually
yeah you weren't super convinced by some
of the specs that they're throwing
around for that one I mean it did seem
like a bit of a hype trailer it's a
they're offering a system on a chip
which is an integrated graphics you know
with a CPU right now if you have a
dedicated graphics card in a computer
spend hundreds of dollars on it it can
maybe do 4k maybe depending on the game
in the settings right so for them to
sort of tout out this you know bring out
Scorpio and say oh yeah I'm compromised
4k gaming the set in the other and
virtual reality like yes limits it's
there blown smoke up people's but like
right I think maybe you're going to see
games scaled to 4k but I still rendered
natively inside the console and lower
resolutions or you're gonna see really
simple games that aren't really
graphically demanding great at 4k
resolution pretty lucky yeah I'm the big
one for me or one of the big ones
battlefield one
oh right it's been as a huge huge fan of
1942 yeah it is so awesome like flying a
plane bombing this guy like and him
using the crater I just cause as cover
right leveling buildings just the
gameplay and even like it for something
like Call of Duty where I feel like
there's a lot of twitch and like you
know a lot of like courage going into an
area and yes getting killed whatever the
pacing is up really quick this is a game
where you have you know lower health I'm
being really conserved mmm I'm terrified
when I step out of a door and reopen
because of so many factors that can kill
me it just like I find myself like
squatting up with guys you know I'm a
medic I'm I'm running across the street
to revive a guy even though I know I'm
gonna die doing it but unless what's the
fog girls in and letting you can yeah
I'm at the dynamic weather I played it
Sunday right and that was just like the
overarching a bigger game mode then we
played domination the second day which
is the smaller we played both modes but
we actually got the dynamic weather on
the second day and I think it'll
eventually be like sand storms in the
Abu Dhabi and then the fog rolled in
when we were playing it's cool because
when you respawn it zooms out on the big
map and then you can see where the fog
is oh wow cool so there's this one field
that we kept keeps getting smoked
because there's a couple machine guns up
on a hill right the fog world ends like
alright and I sprinted across the field
no one even saw me so I was fine but the
same time it also creates like snipers
are kind of useless
yeah but scouts have a flare that they
can shoot up so we tried doing it I
didn't actually succeed in doing it but
I could see some people doing it when
there's fog you can shoot up a flare and
then get out of there so the bombers
know where to hit in the fog right yeah
it's wow so great is that you think
about you know the entirety of the game
and how it changes in dynamically
rightly so at this fog moment it's not
my goal now to attack the ground it
separates ya players and basically
having an air game it's like a shift of
focus yeah like a different part but but
shooting a flare up will help Bombers
yeah on that area everything I've heard
from people playing about field one has
been incredibly positive yeah guy I have
one question that I've seen a lot of the
chat say as well is that does it feel
like a reskin still does it feel like
sort of a slab of paint
you know the battlefield vietnam about
94 now if there's a feel like a new
battlefield feels like it feels like a
new battlefield but it's still kind of a
return to like the 1942 roots and in
like these larger battles that it's more
it's not about like reflexes like Call
of Duty like Rob said it's more
positioning yourself so you can be
effective it's doing something like
helping out something like Rob said ah
the destruction was kind of a cool thing
when the artillery we heard them like
whistling it was a 64 player game like
five of us were in this one capture zone
artillery you can hear it come whistling
and were like ah [ __ ] right and it
starts killed all of us except for it
kill everyone except for me I was half
dead but I crawled into one of the
craters that the artillery itself had
made and then I just I didn't even shoot
my gun I just like just by staying the
capture zone and getting like my
teammates up there in our eyes yeah it's
just like things like that where you
don't actually you don't have to be
shooting someone to be helping you can
just be actually like the world itself
is dictating how you play and that's why
it feels like the those older
battlefield games with like with actual
substance that's awesome stylistically
it's it's killer to I mean just the grit
of it it's you know it just like you
know Spielberg with Private Ryan right
right you get that filter on yet the
embers of fire like or bright bright
orange like you just get a really great
visual style that I think it's
completely unique - awesome - this
series cool could see that orange and
teal from their posters finally getting
into the video exactly before we talk
about the big one is there any other
ones you guys want to mention quickly
all the games that you were impressed by
we just had the folks on I keep
forgetting the name of this game days
gone we just had those folks on I'm
really impressed by that I like the idea
of a small sort of team that
series that they worked on for so long
we've kind of been you know sitting on
the bench for Sony for a long time
actually getting a game like it's based
around there they're like you know there
it reminds me of CD Projekt a bit with
The Witcher where it's like it's based
around where they're from and it's like
they feel really lucky to be working on
this big franchise so I kind of hope
they pull that one off
where is it it's open somewhere in
Oregon Oh Pacific nor'wester Base so
nice it's only been so just how a son is
a member games before we get to the
actually had just played lawbreakers all
right one this morning and I wasn't
playing a good amount of overwatch my
god it's so overwatch in a very positive
way like I mixed quake right like yeah
like super bad what was all that who can
sort of zero-g stuff like basically
there were three points capture points
the middle capture point where everyone
kind of collides is all zero-g so you
just you get in there and next you know
everything changes yeah you know there
was one character that was so diva wise
in every shape and form and they even
have like lines and quips and stuff like
that that they say when they kill people
she's jetting around with them like a
minigun and you're like you're shooting
Rockets you get flown back yeah I'm the
zero-g I could say stuff but it's nice
this I love it when I see people explode
right you know the compared to I mean
that's the thing right you say it's like
overwatch but then also I mean the
classic Unreal Tournament yellow
disgustingness yeah that's fun I enjoy
it they got a beta that one there's
alpha this weekend this weekend right
okay host but I want an cliffy B you can
get in on that okay but yeah we there
are so many games to talk about we
talked about so many of them in our pre
and post-show and obviously that a lot
not on this stage but with on
gamespot.com and on youtube.com for such
GameSpot and all our sort of reaction
videos but the one I keep hearing people
talk about and it's the one that's got
all the biggest lines and stairs and
it's like the only game they brought
it's a classic Nintendo you put all your
eggs in one basket but god dammit those
are some good [ __ ] eggs
Peter Brian tell me about Zelda Zelda is
the only game I can think about and
everyone I've talked to has only
positive things to say but more than
that every single person I talked to has
a different experience to share and now
granted like a game like Battlefield or
lawbreakers will give you those
different experiences but the things
people are describing in Zelda are you
know these systems sort of piling on top
of each other where
maybe you saw one cool ability in one
location right and another and another
one you can start combining and like
chaining those together in ways that are
just so astounding to me like let me
have some examples sure like for example
the would see like okay so horse riding
right flip off your horse get into a
hang glider right drop that land on your
horse's head jump off him
right get your bone arrow slow moan are
there Epona huh Epona no no it's a wild
horse oh right okay REE okay did not
know that that's the thing any anything
you talk about this game you can just be
like no no it's there's like a whole
other thing to every little nuance right
I was expecting old Zelda yeah yeah no
you can okay jump off a cliff use your
hang glider Lance no board on your
shield do a spin to attack enemies use
your bow and arrow while doing it and
then just like you know as Rob was
telling me yesterday like stop mid slide
it's like put your thing on your back
and like keep walking away like a jerk
oh man you said the hang gliding uh the
gift that you showed me earlier Twitter
was yeah it was but it was he had
started a fire oh right right so he's on
the horse there's a firing from him with
a boss and past that he uses the fire
heat and wind - then get higher no and
then get into slow-mo and fire the ice
arrow oh yeah okay
this is actually my gameplay so what had
this is a taupe freakin cool this is the
first thing I saw in my 45 minute what a
demo he shot an arrow and a beehive all
fine there's the bees but they scared
away the enemies at the camp in turn
they drop their weapon the shot so the
phone oh thank you I know so I either oh
I had the dev play but we just kind of
ask them to do a bunch of stuff um shot
that rope no but again we you scare the
monsters away from the camp so they drop
their weapons right and then you attack
them so you stealth to basically make
situations easier I mean this is all
it's a sort of emergent combat you used
to in like games like like theif you're
like you're going in with all your
various tools and sort of combining them
in interesting ways - yeah yeah that's
something we really I mean exploration
is always going to matter part of this
in puzzle solving for sure but not the
type of puzzle solving that's like like
you were talking we had them on Peter
was it two days ago and you're saying
like
they with the with the you know the
hearts for instance you know the hearts
used to be to just collect them cutting
grass or whatever right is this abstract
kind of thing yeah I think they torn
away this level of abstraction right but
they seem to have done this sort of all
over the place then they're just like
you've entered the rules yeah yeah in
the game yeah like you know I was just
shot right here if I can skip a minute
just so good yeah like you know some
what do you guys was telling you you can
pick a belief and you can use this leaf
or value later and like well yeah yeah
so like you know one point you get a
raft and I forget what the other
function of the leaf was it has multiple
but it's actually just generates wind so
right he was using it to knock people
off cliffs right oh here's the
snowboarding one yeah like oh yeah
actually does like the so yeah and so
when you're on the raft you can use it
to blow the sails you know yeah it's
like everything is built around these
rules and it's right back and just
applications for each item and you just
can see just the shrines with like you
know you get these abilities like
generate an ice lift right right you
just can start seeing these fit into a
bigger picture of just combinations all
right well it's like you know Zelda
classically I'm not the massive the big
Zelda nerd here by any means I played
definitely the least almost for in the
catch and probably at least of anyone in
the office but there was always this
thing of like here is the ice level here
is the fire temple right and it's almost
as if they'd taken those individualistic
sort of rule sets that were in those
temples and I just like plastered them
across the entire for help like said
have a dash like they're combining as
well yeah it totally seems like there's
I mean they should the map we were
playing on was I think some people one
person said 5% and then someone else
came up to corrector and 701 percent
yeah and it was almost Oh big boy I use
oom doubt it was it's pretty was a 10
times the size of Twilight Princess
which is a pretty big full-time
sometimes uh but yeah it definitely
there's different biomes like I mean
that you know there's the winter area
then there's the more kind of like
marshy you start off in this light kind
of just regular deciduous forests and
fields where yeah
and there are still dungeons you know
that which are now known as shrines
there are a hundred of them okay so
here's yeah here's this moment where
it's like freezing water like you what's
what you start seeing the chopping down
trees aspect and also the physics of it
are outstanding I mean you bright hiccup
or
alright let y'all it's none of that it's
like that Nintendo polish but also in
like physics okay yeah this is the
biggest game they've ever made like
they're on record saying they have the
most people working on this game that
any a degree they've ever made before
like including like galaxies and all you
know you think about it so no no we
asked him during interview like is this
the biggest production or you know
whatever and he was like yeah like no
like Oh what kind of rice yeah did I
yeah I came in I just played ten minutes
ago I rushed up here after playing and
the last thing I did I didn't even know
I had the bombs to match ones which are
only a meter now kind of right they're
not a Qantas you know quantity of them
it's just yep just make it cool down or
whatever I pulled it out on accident and
then I was like oh I should get rid of
this cuz it's like knowing Zelda or what
I thought I knew like it was throwing
off my so I threw it and then it's like
detonate I was like and I was trying to
figure out what it was telling them is
like oh [ __ ] so but it had rolled down a
hill by that point yeah I pressed it it
blew up the bottom of a tree which fell
on a book on oh yeah and then I'll
covers I pick up his giant axe I'm like
swung it and the axe it's not as
powerful it's not doesn't like do as
much damage as the sword I think like a
PS or whatever you want to talk about
knocked him over he like got stunned
fell backwards into the fire he was set
on fire and that his weapon itself was
also on fire so I picked that up and
threw to someone else and set them on
which does double damage when you throw
away and I don't like it i deflected an
arrow with a shield like back at him
whoa on accident kind of because I was
like yeah the controls don't feel like a
normal Zelda right now right game pad or
whatever so yeah so I was like press a
on accent and I was like oh that's a
shield thing so I deflection so I kind
of swing it twice and hit an arrow it
killed him so he's like these little
mechanical touches and there's so much
personality as well like right the bombs
you're describing when they detonate
link kind of has this motion where he
like thrusts his hands out and opens his
palm like he's got some sort of like
magical it does have this magical power
over it you know all these little things
like when he's cold he's like shivering
when he eats it's like this big jack I
need my little stealth mechanic that
they have him there with yeah the audio
levels like oh right yeah it's a super
weird
aesthetic to cuz hit like when you pull
up your map in the game he has like this
game high-fiving device yeah right
unlike the xxi that's what Randy is
thinking like he believes that that's
all
using NFC like you're doing things with
this that you would use a modern piece
of technology for all right it's not
just a thing that has a screen so
Randy's starting to think maybe it's
indicative of what we're gonna see on
you know
yeah extra hardware well yeah I mean I'm
the other thing I guess is that there
was there was this kind of wonder this
question that okay we're releasing this
on NX will it be the same game on both
platforms yeah I mean it's not like
they're going to be able to change this
right I think it's too big a project
yeah so they so you're thinking then ok
the NX is going to be this traditional
type of it will at least support
traditional controllers that you're
familiar with yeah what it will do
beyond that beyond the gamepad we don't
know did you get any information as to
story stuff Y wider than what they
talked about Landry yeah I've been
asleep for a hundred years you wake up
because you there's these two chests one
with God one with a basic one to do one
with a shirt and one pants you put them
on okay for the print of the demo you
already already know enough but one of
the fast friend points they respond is
the shrine of awakening whatever and you
leave and go yeah it's a basically the
story is a hundred years ago
calamity Ganon God is like he's like an
entity now not rapper yeah early work
you know he's like this cloud of smoke
over Hyrule Castle and you've been
asleep for a hundred years and gaining
is now at the point where he's about to
be powerful enough to take over all of
Hyrule okay so you were you were woken
up to basically be like alright now is
your time to put your powers to the ten
words you're the doom marine babe yeah
exactly though it's that exactly and so
yeah that's kind of the main story but
when the interesting things that they've
said a couple times now which I still
find so fascinating is if you are a good
enough player you can start from the
very beginning and go straight to the
final boss Wow and beat it without
experiencing any of the story you know
like that's like the opposite of what
Zelda has been yeah engages since the
first game yeah they just an adult you
needed this award yeah this tree yeah
got some instructions for you Pete now
we're talking about how like this is the
closest there's a lot of like Zelda
purists who think that the first game is
still like one of the best because it's
an actual open world where like all the
most every single other Zelda is like a
false open world on my tomates yeah but
like link between worlds got a little
closer to that on the 3ds and then now
we have this and this is almost like the
game a lot of Zelda
have been like waiting flick between
worlds I feel like did it in a way that
was kind of like cold and calculated
like yeah how do we change it oh we
strip away you know the need to go in a
certain order by just giving them access
to whatever they want yeah but at the
same time then then you were prepared
for what you were going to do because
you said I'm taking this item to go do
this thing
this game doesn't give you that you have
to be resourceful and acquire everything
on your own through your knowledge
through your ability and like that's
that's really impressive the onus is on
you to be successful the onus is on you
to define how you're going to be
successful and it will do it in so many
ways very impressive
everyone's come back who's played it has
been a very speaking highly of us it's
going to be annoying that you guys won't
be able to play it again for quite a
while yeah I mean it'll least be a no I
got it the game good got the UH next
asleep over everybody come to my house
tomorrow Rob now invited I mean the ex
is supposed to come out March of next
year right so it's gonna be available
simultaneously on both platforms this is
the sort of game where people are saying
I'm gonna buy in a next day one we don't
even know what the hell NX is yet but
they want the best version of this game
and they're willing to throw hundreds of
dollars at it not knowing what sort of
hardware like that's impressive as hell
yeah of the wild breath of fresh air
that was this little shell
Orma sitting up here but we have squall
just drops my Mike's gone is it really
oh I thought it was like oh I gotta do
my Tom Jones bit now well that's a shame
thank you so much to everyone for
watching thank you so much Adam applause
to all the people behind this yeah
mr. and the man from Down Under
on the Wheels of Steel Edie trying for
directing this whole thing as well
congratulations
alright and thank you I thank you so
much for watching on twitch on YouTube
on gamespot.com
on Facebook wherever you are I thank you
so much for watching our show here
downstairs all of our impressions
there's loads more videos to check out
on gamespot.com and on YouTube as well
thank you so much for supporting us it's
been a blast and an honor hosting here
with everyone else and thank you guys
for putting in such amazing work as well
it's easy
congratulate good yeah games are good
another great year at e3 thank you so
much folks take care of yourselves out
there we'll see you next year at e3 but
we'll see you in the next couple of days
on gamespot.com
adios